décrypter les méandres du cerveau
détecte et les pulsions criminelles pour
prévenir l'irréparable de la science
fiction
oui mais la réalité s'en rapproche peu à
peu je vais vous installez le casque sur
la tête dès 2015 des chercheurs
sonderont le cerveau de délinquants
sexuels
dans ce nouveau laboratoire de
l'institut philippe-pinel de montréal
pour le moment question joyal examine
les réactions du cerveau à des stimuli
sexuels chez la population en général
jusqu'à présent une quarantaine de
volontaires ont participé à son étude
pour présente des films où il ya des
acteurs qui bouge qui font les mêmes à
peu près le même type de mouvement à la
même fréquence que dans les films
érotiques puis aussi des films avec des
émotions positives pendant la diffusion
de ces vidéos
l'équipe de recherche 8 en temps réel
l'activité cérébrale du participant le
mouvement des yeux et aussi scruté à la
loupe
tout comme la circonférence du pénis
mesurer grâce à une électrode c'est plus
pour être capable de dd à évaluer
quelqu'un on le soupçonne d'être serrée
sexuellement par des avants si on peut
lui demander ça vaut ce que ça vaut plus
que les intérêts sexuels déviants c'est
un indice significatif pour un réseau
récidive c'est aussi intéressant de
pouvoir avoir une façon d évalue aussi
en cours de traitement
pour terminer ce traitement fait un
effet quelconque grâce à une voûte
d'immersion virtuelle
les chercheurs mesure où si le degré
d'empathie de leur sujet il leur
présente des avatars comme cet homme en
douleur on a vu que les gens qui ont des
traits de psychopathie sol le démontrer
cet été ceux qui ont des traits
discopathie leur cerveau réagissent
moins dans l'avenir les chercheurs
pourraient utiliser un avatar d'enfants
dans le cas de pédophiles à condition
que le comité d'éthique de l'institut
philippe-pinel accepte ce n'est donc pas
demain la veille que cette expertise se
retrouvera dans les tribunaux les
tribunaux sont toujours un peu
conservateur relativement à tout ce qui
vaud d'autant que les délinquants
sexuels peuvent tromper la machine non
postaux a infligé une blessure
le mieux c'est seulement de la langue
l'intérieur de la lèvre et donc la
douleur la douleur le cerveau réagit
tout donc on vient d'invalider les
résultats christian joyal lui n'est pas
pressée de se retrouver dans les
tribunaux à titre d'expert il veut
mettre à l'épreuve ces nouveaux outils
simon 10e peut on peut démontrer sage
est très content mais des fois c'est
d'abord c'est un projet de ville c'est
ici marié cousineau radio canada
montréal